so I've got these two I've got an
expression for AF an expression for bf I
should put that down here bless you and
you can see what this gives us is every
measurement in this bottom triangle the
ground triangle does that make sense
that's this a B F that I've got here
it's right angle I have all three sides
what piece of knowledge should I call on
right angle triangle we give links this
is Pythagoras right thank you so I'm
gonna say in triangle a B F because
again I'm now thinking of a different
triangle to state the soon I'm just
gonna go ahead and state Pythagoras
right let's see which one's the
hypotenuse and look it's the 15 in mine
and you to use your own length for yours
so I'm gonna have whatever squared plus
y squared equals that hypotenuse squared
15 squared H squared
cot squared so this is what I'm gonna
put into my calculator like so yeah we
are gonna have to put it in but
thankfully we're not going to do most of
the grunt work the calculator is going
to do now plus h squared cot squared 31
and that's equal to that's the a squared
that's the B squared and then C squared
here's my hypotenuse didn't leave myself
enough space but I should say the reason
that's a good question can anyone help
out to him why is the 44 the angle there
why is that not square one up to 44
degrees squared
why wouldn't I touch that big yeah I'm
kind of squaring already this whole
wherever I written here's the whole
length right this whole page so in fact
it's this entire object all is one that
I'm squaring the angle there
I want that still be 44 degrees what is
44 squared like 716 hey I have no idea
what it is right but that angle that
angle doesn't need to change the angle
is fine just leave it don't square that
that make sense okay now I want what was
the thing I was after what am I actually
trying to work out I what behind the
flagpole right so you're going to what
to be the subject so I'm going to divide
or I'm going to factorize rather take
that H squared out of you cut squared 44
squared 31 I'm going to leave that as 15
squared you'll see why in about 30
seconds divide through to get h squared
on its own and I know this looks a bit
gross however really calculator is gonna
be doing all the heavy lifting for us
okay why do you think I left that 15
squared as 15 square rather than saying
225 and what am I gonna do in the next
line yeah I'm gonna take the square root
so I'm like I don't want h squared I
just want H so on my final line here
we'll second to final before I actually
chuck it into the calculator yeah it's
it's on the top here so I've divided
both sides by this awful gross mess here
all right so I've just divided this by
this and I've divided this by the same
thing which is what no longer appears on
the left hand side good question all
right let's finish off this
gross-looking fractured here yeah just
be really careful as you input this into
your calculator there's a lot of little
terms there you don't have a cut button
on your calculator unfortunately so you
are gonna have to do one on etc
something you might find handy is you
can store variables in your calculator
how we showed you how to do this yet
have you seen how to do it did it hand
start okay let's do this yeah yeah you
can you can store variables in your
calculator so sito can I borrow yours
actually is that Alright thank you no
that's that statistics oh by the way
he's my wacky mm-hm
stay stay stay here we go
that's exactly what we just looked at
but I'm gonna switch over to second
okay here we go all right so can you see
that all right now on mine a value that
I was using was 10 so I caught 44 right
that's what I actually wanted but it's
really awkward you could have brackets
and brackets on fractions on the square
roots it's quite gross right so here's
what I'm gonna do instead I'm gonna say
just calculate and we're in radians at
the moment so I'm just gonna switch that
over shift said let's make sure we're
all the degrees press 3 I'm gonna
calculate one on 1044 see that that
number there that's caught 44 and I'm
gonna use this number later on so once
you've got it in the display you've hit
equals okay what you want to go for is
see this button I see I'll desert no it
stands for it's very close
ah CL stands for recall so if I store a
value I can recall it I can find out
what it is but just above it it's quite
hard to see one here look it's s TF is
store right so he's not good gonna do
shift store
let's press that right now shift store
you'll know you did it right because the
sto is highlighted at the top now did
you notice just on all these little
little buttons here you've got those red
letters right so that's what they're for
ABCDE F X Y M what should we call it
let's call it X so just tap on that
button with the X on it okay so just
once you've done shift store you just
press that button there it's the it's
the bracket right now if you did it
right do you see what the display say
whatever answer you just got it's now X
right that one point zero three etc okay
so remember how I said recall is this
button here if you forgot what you
stored in there you just say recall X
well I press the wrong button sorry I'm
upside down recall X is that better pimp
there you go okay so now when I'm
putting this into my calculator I can
instead of saying one odd blah blah blah
I can just say for instance what did I
have on the top I think I had 15 on what
did I have here the square root where's
the square button it's really hard to
see upside down there we go
and to get to X I have to press alpha x
squared I need the rest of it it's not
finished because that's
one of the cuts I need the other cut as
well but that will just make it easier
to input and less chance of screw your
brackets okay
now you've got your own measurements
here's what I want you to do instead of
having a look at my numbers which look
like this that's that's the distance I
got at the bottom here just by putting
my numbers in but they were fabricated
you have actual measurements okay so can
you have a look
cross-check it against the people beside
you and see how accurate you got your
measurement there you go